it's not truffles that ondrea's Paulo is
searching for here in the alpine forest
he's a sorcerer and supplier of tonewood
timber with the right acoustic
properties for making talk calibers
string instruments in this case spruce
the toughest part is translating the
language or the requirements of the
violin maker back into the appropriate
wood you have to find trees that
correspond exactly to what the people
who work with the wood want
being able to see the tone wood for the
trees requires specialist knowledge that
explains why andreas pollard's customers
travel so far to see him genre Pasha
song is a violin maker from France
coming here to Bavaria meant taking a
1000 kilometer trip the violin makers
it's a little crazy about the wood
the wood suppliers have high standards
only one in a hundred trees provide the
necessary quality of tone wood and
Leia's poller comes across his personal
favorite only every five years or so the
timber is left to dry for five years
initially the supplier has to check the
wood on a daily basis over time he can
tell how good the wood is it's clean but
it does have a sound but it's still dull
and it decays right away the wood isn't
mature yet it needs more time to dry but
it has the potential to develop
positively but there's more to building
a quality instrument than just the right
planks the key to a good table is found
in this little rod which has to be
carefully checked this isn't this is a
sound post it gets inserted in a
vertical position the sound post is the
sole of the violin it transfers the
vibrations that constitute the sound no
violin making set is complete without
one two-thirds of the wood on tania's
collar supplies ends up abroad his
French visitor spends five hours
checking cello parts
he makes just three of the instruments a
year each with a price tag of 28,000
euros so the wood has to be top-notch
he spent 2,000 euros on tone wood for
cello tops bats and finger boards his
next visit won't be for another year
meanwhile ondrea's Paulo will get back
on the trail looking for the next tree
with those prized musical properties